the technology that allows
filmmaking to be uh more practical
is kind of the most is the stuff i get
most excited about
um on top gun uh we
we worked with sony to develop a
uh an imax quality camera that's
about this big um and only like two
inches deep so we were able to mount
six of them inside the cockpit um
and four on the outside of the airplane
so in that case we're using technology
to capture something
real rather than having to create it on
a sound stage
um so that was for me was kind of
was one of the things that that i was
excited about in you know
jumping into the project in the first
place what's the resolution on something
like that and how does it compare to a
film camera
it's a uh it's a 6k camera so
um 6000 pixels wide it's a large format
sensor
which is bigger than a 35 millimeter
sensor um
it's like a cinemascope i think is the
is this you know the comparable film
size
uh the the real technology breakthrough
is that the sensor can be separated from
the recorder
so when you're looking at a digital
camera the the only thing capturing the
image is that first
inch of the camera everything kind of
behind that is power and recording and
cooling and so uh this sony camera which
is called the sony venice
you can buy a version where those two
pieces are connected
via uh some fiber optic cable
so the sensor with a very small lens
can sit in a place you know very tight
place
or right in front of the actor we had
four of them pointing at the actor um
on top gun and the recorders could be
hidden in storage spaces on the jet
uh so you're just able to put you know
something that
normally you know normally you'd only be
able to fit a gopro there now you're
able to put a
imax quality camera in that spot
uh in this case six of them so we have
multi-camera
coverage um of these sequences uh
that you can cut a whole scene by just
working with those six
angles so um that to me was kind of our
our technology breakthrough on
on this movie and it's just a really fun
way to work when
you're getting it all in camera